qu'est ce qui a bien pu se passer dans
ce retrouvé mort sur le lieu du crime un
gâteau au chocolat un chat et du poison
c'est parti pour relever les empreintes
et trouver quel poudre et toxiques
tout était devenue marron et ça faisait
des espèces de
peut-il lui loue des choses dans le
genre c'était pas très un petit peu
bizarre
les autres actions étaient habitués des
habitudes plus allez voir que cette
réaction n'a jamais vue des exercices
pour leur apprendre les sciences mais
aussi arraisonné et des du professeur
garnoulles ses enfants mènent l'enquêté
pour retrouver le coupable grâce aux
analyses médico légales
pendant une semaine on fait un stage
scientifique donc tous les jours on a un
atelier sur un thème différent donc
aujourd'hui c'était sur la police
scientifique la science médico légal ils
deviennent des experts ils sont mises en
situation voilà on essaie de de créer un
petit imaginaire au siec des petites
enquêtes qu'elle tombe bien parce que
vous faisiez plusieurs choses on faisait
pas les mêmes choses hein pas pareil
donc assez bien malgré les apparences ce
n'est pas le chat le coupable
résultat après investigations le
chocolat est toxique pour les chiens
pendant les vacances le centre alfred de
vigny propose d'autres stages pour
devenir potier au créer son propre jeu
vidéo